welcome back to the ingram angle imagine
walking into your state's capitol during
the week of christmas and seeing this
monstrosity it's a so-called art display
in illinois depicting the satanic figure
baphomet as a baby it sits right next to
the nativity it's so obvious what the
satanic temple the group who put this
thing on is doing they are mocking
religious expression and the nativity
joining me now is reverend franklin
graham he's president and ceo of
samaritan's purse reverend graham merry
christmas your reaction to this
blasphemous image at the illinois
capitol
well first of all the devil has been
trying to destroy christmas for 2 000
years when
king herod
sent his troops to bethlehem to hunt for
the baby jesus to kill him and so the
devil has been trying to destroy
christmas ever since and this is just
another very sad attempt but your
christmas is about god's love it's not
about the satanic temple it's about god
so loving this world that he sent his
son jesus christ to this earth to take
our sins jesus died for our sins he was
buried he rose again he's alive if we're
willing to repent turn from those sins
and put our faith and trust in him god
will forgive our sins and he'll heal our
hearts and he'll invite us to be with
him for eternity but this is what
christmas is all about it's about god
loving this earth and loving you and
loving me
reverend graham i need to ask you about
this new poll that just came out the
percentage of americans who identify as
christian has dropped 15 percent over
the last 14 years it's now about three
in 10 adults who consider themselves
religious nons which are atheists or
agnostics or just nothing
why is this happening and what can the
church do about it
well i think the church has got a lot of
work to do and we need to be doing
evangelism uh we need to be sharing with
people how they can have a relationship
with god uh through faith in christ i'm
not talking about religion there's a lot
of religion in the world and i'm talking
about how you can have a relationship
with god
and that's through faith in his son
jesus christ so i think we got a lot of
work i'm certainly not going to be able
to be out of a job i don't think
because there's a lot of work to do and
i hope that pastors and churches across
this country will be willing to preach
and tell others how they can have that
relationship with jesus christ
despite those trying to divide the
country uh reverend
samaritan's purse your group is bringing
people together for operation christmas
child now i know our producer every year
she and her son stuffs their uh shoebox
presents are donated and delivered to
children all over the world who may
otherwise get nothing how many gifts are
you set to distribute this christmas
uh this year we've taken in just a
little over 10 million i think it's
about 10.2 million
shoeboxes and this will be delivered to
children in 110 different countries and
so it's it's an incredible program and
these are children who have nothing
children when you give them a gift for
many it's to phone a gift they've ever
received in the life
and the joy and the hope that it gives
them and you know the fact that they
know that somebody out there loves them
somebody out there hadn't forgotten them
and i want the children of the world to
know the true meaning of christmas about
god's love
now like the wise men we continue giving
on christ's birthday to the rest of the
world to those nearest uh samaritan's
purse is also putting a lot of effort i
know
into helping those devastated by the
tornadoes in kentucky and arkansas
franklin you have hundreds of volunteers
on the ground right now what are you
doing to help what can viewers do to
help and how are you spending your
christmas eve
well i'm going to be
let me answer the question of how what a
person can do then go to our website
samaritansperson.org and find out how
they can volunteer or how they can be a
part of helping this relief effort but
i'm going to be there christmas eve
we're going to serve a christmas lunch
to about 5 000 people ricky skaggs is
going to be with me and we're going to
serve from 11
to about 3 in the afternoon and it's for
everybody in the mayfield area
they can come by and have a free lunch
and ricky will play and i'm going to say
a few words to them
and so then we work on christmas we will
have teams of people working through
christmas uh we don't take christmas off
the people up there need our help now
and i think it's important that we stay
there through christmas helping them
well god bless you reverend graham and
your efforts
merry christmas to you and to all those
at samaritan's purse and thank you for
your great work